Herzlich willkommen zu Dicke Bretter, der ist schon in der Nummer 10 diesmal.
Ein Podcast von und mit Elisa Lindinger und Constanze Kurz. Und heute fehlt in der Runde Khaleesi.
Aber das macht nichts, weil wir einen Gast haben, den wir gleich vorstellen.
Aber ich will noch ein paar Sätze sagen zu unserem Podcast.
Dicke Bretter versucht sich aus der Perspektive der Zivilgesellschaft so an
dieses klassische Thema, wie entsteht politische Willensbildung?
Wie laufen diese Prozesse ab?
Sowohl in Europa wie auch im Bundestag, wie vielleicht in den Ländern oder Kommunen.
Also das ist so unser Oberthema.
Wir hatten verschiedene Themen und heute haben wir einen besonderen Gast, nämlich Simone Ruf.
Und Simone hat ein paar Erfahrungen gemacht in den letzten Monaten,
über die wir reden wollen und wo wir so ein bisschen erklären wollen,
Wie so die Abläufe sind und wie man sich das vorstellen kann.
Nämlich, Simone war Sachverständige in verschiedenen Ausschüssen und darüber wollen wir reden.
Und Lisa Lindinger, die hier auch sitzt, hat ebenfalls Erfahrungen beizusteuern,
weil sie auch mehrfach in solchen Anhörungen war.
Und ich selber. Ich heiße Konstanze. Wir wollen alle so ein bisschen unsere
Erfahrungen einbringen in diesem Bereich.
Aber zunächst mal, weil sie ja unser Gast ist,
Wollen wir Simone ein bisschen vorstellen. Und wie vielleicht einige wissen,
haben Simone und ich letztes Jahr beim Kongress einen Vortrag gehalten über Palantir.
Und darüber kennen wir uns auch, also so haben wir uns eigentlich kennengelernt.
Aber ich glaube, in der weiteren Öffentlichkeit ist er bekannt wegen der GFF,
also der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, wo sie arbeitet.
Erzähl doch mal, Simone, was machst du da und wie bist du dazu gekommen?
Ja, danke erstmal, dass ich da sein darf. Das ist natürlich eine große Ehre.
Und genau, ein Thema, das uns auf jeden Fall verbindet, ist Palantir.
Einmal natürlich beim CCC, aber auch in anderen Konstellationen und darüber
hinaus noch. Ich arbeite bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte.
Die kennt man ja wahrscheinlich schon aus anderen Folgen. Jedenfalls einer,
in der meine Kollegin Svea schon da war.
Wir machen strategische Prozessführung, also strategische Klagen,
immer mit dem Ziel, Erfolge für Grund- und Menschenrechte zu erwirken.
Und haben da auch verschiedene Schwerpunktbereiche und ich bin in dem Schwerpunkt
Freiheit im digitalen Zeitalter als Juristin.
Und da geht es vor allem um klassische Überwachungsthemen, deswegen auch das
Thema Palantir, also Data Mining, aber auch gerade wieder aktueller biometrische
Gesichtserkennung ist so ein zweites Thema, zu dem ich viel arbeite.
Wir wollen das nicht hinterm Berg halten. Du bist Doktor der Jurisprudenz.
Du hast also hohe akademische Weile.
Und hast aber, glaube ich, mittlerweile nach dem Studium hier bei der GFF angefangen,
oder? Oder hast du Zwischenschritte noch gehabt?
Genau, also im Jurastudium muss man ja immer so verschiedenste Schritte machen.
Das erste, erstmal so ein erstes Staatsexamen schreiben. Dazwischen habe ich
promoviert, dann das zweite gemacht und war dann, glücklicherweise konnte ich
meine Wahlstation im Referendariat bei der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte
machen und hatte dann Glück, dass sich danach direkt eine Stelle ergeben hat.
Genau.
Wie kam es jetzt dazu, dass du das allererste Mal als Sachverständiger in irgendeiner Anhörung kamst?
Wie lief das praktisch ab, damit sich jemand, der noch niemals Sachverständiger
war, vorstellen kann, wie das läuft?
Ich war natürlich ultra aufgeregt. Neue Situation.
Die mündliche Anhörung läuft dann so, man kommt irgendwie an,
wird dann in diesen Sitzungssaal geleitet.
Da sieht man dann schon seinen Namen irgendwo stehen und die ganzen anderen
Sachverständigen, von denen ich ehrlich gesagt niemanden wirklich kannte.
Okay, keine Gesprächspartner in der Pause davor, sondern einfach unbekannte Menschen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, ich war auch aufgeregt und habe mich auch so ein bisschen
abgesondert. Genau, so ist ja auch deine Strategie in so einer Situation.
Ich hatte aber den Eindruck, dass sich viele schon unter einander erkannten.
Genau, dann setzt man sich hin, dann geht es eigentlich auch relativ fix los, war meine Erfahrung.
Man hat drei Minuten Zeit für ein Eingangsstatement, das kennt ihr ja wahrscheinlich.
Das ist schon relativ knackig, ehrlich gesagt. Zum Teil sind auch Sachverständige
zugeschaltet, also man muss gar nicht unbedingt vor Ort sein.
Dann sitzen so halbkreisförmig die Abgeordneten drumherum und wenn dann alle
die Eingangsstatements durchhaben, dann geht es mit einer Fragerunde los,
die aber auch zeitlich stark beschränkt ist und man hat dann auch jeweils nur
zwei Minuten, glaube ich, Zeit, um zu antworten.
Simone, sag doch nochmal ganz kurz, um welches Gremium geht es hier eigentlich?
In welchem Ausschuss warst du, von welchem Parlament?
Ja, genau. Wichtige Information natürlich. Also es ging um den Bundestag und
ich war im Innenausschuss. Oh, okay.
Und der Innenausschuss hat auch genau diese Regeln mit diesem dreiminütigen
Eingangsstatement und wir können vielleicht mal sagen, oder sagst du mal,
Elisa, war bei dir das auch immer so?
Also ist das auch genau deine Erfahrung oder hast du auch andere,
ein bisschen lockere Regeln vorgefunden?
Tatsächlich, was den Bundestag angeht, hatte ich glaube ich einfach eine bis
zwei Minuten mehr als du.
Ob das dann gut ist oder schlecht ist, ob ich das maximal ausgereizt habe oder
nicht, steht auf einem anderen Blatt.
Aber tatsächlich, ich war einmal in der letzten Legislatur noch im ADA,
im Ausschuss Digitale Agenda und jetzt in dieser Legislatur im AD,
im Ausschuss für Digitales.
Und da waren es jeweils vier bis fünf Minuten.
Also ein bisschen länger als im Innenausschuss. Und haben die Sachverständigen
das da auch ausgenutzt oder reden die kürzer oder länger? Oder haben die sich
da, weiß ich nicht, wie alternde Professoren manchmal so sind, 25 Minuten ausgewählt?
Oder war die Vorsitzende oder der Vorsitzende streng?
Also bei mir zumindest waren alle sehr diszipliniert, hatte ich das Gefühl.
Also du merkst schon, dass die Leute, die dort reden, diese Chance ernst nehmen
und sich darauf sehr intensiv vorbereiten.
Und fünf Minuten oder auch drei Minuten sind keine lange Zeit.
Das heißt, wirklich auch durchzudenken, was sind denn die Kernpunkte,
die ich jetzt drüber bringen möchte in dieser kurzen Redezeit,
die mir auf jeden Fall zusteht.
Also insofern waren alle sehr diszipliniert, weil sie einfach gut vorbereitet waren.
Und insofern musste die Vorsitzende im Digitalausschuss konkret,
Tabea Rösner, musste jetzt, glaube ich, auch nicht so streng mit uns sein, weil wir sehr gut waren.
Und hattest du in deinem jetzt konkreten Fall, den du eben meintest,
auch eine schriftliche Stellungnahme abgegeben dazu?
Ja, da hatte ich auch eine schriftliche Stellungnahme abgegeben.
Das ist eigentlich der normale Ablauf, dass man auf jeden Fall die Gelegenheit
hat, eine schriftliche Stellungnahme vorab abzugeben, die dann,
glaube ich, ja vor allem dazu dienen soll, dass die Abgeordneten die Fragen
darauf aufbauen können.
Hatten die die gelesen deinem Eindruck nach? Also hattest du den Eindruck,
das, was vorher auch nicht nur von dir, sondern auch von den anderen Sachverständigen
abgegeben wurde, war schon Teil?
Oder habt ihr da viel wiederholt, was schon schriftlich aufgeschrieben wurde?
Also ich glaube, man hat, oder ich habe auf jeden Fall schon nochmal viel wiederholt,
natürlich fokussierter.
Ich weiß, das weiß ich nicht genau, ob alle wirklich alles lesen und in welcher Detailliertheit.
Und ich glaube, so um Um die eigenen wichtigen Punkte machen zu können,
ist es schon wichtig, in dem Eingangsstatement einfach nochmal kurz die Chance
zu nutzen, um da den Fokus auf die Argumente zu legen.
In deinem Fall war ja kein konkreter Gesetzentwurf jetzt da,
sondern es war ein Antrag und zwar auch ein Antrag, wenn ich mich recht entsinne,
der Opposition, korrekt?
Genau.
Welchen Inhalt, was wollten die eigentlich diese, also sozusagen die Oppositionsparteien,
warum musste der Innenausschuss tagen?
Ja, die wollten, dass der Bundestag beschließt, dass Palantir auch auf Bundesebene
eingesetzt werden darf. Also die Software kennt man ja aus einigen Bundesländern
und das sollte der Bundestag beschließen nach diesem Antrag.
Wie war das bei dir? Was war der Zweck, warum ihr zusammenkommt?
Es gab da auch einen bestimmten Antrag, war ja auch ohne Gesetzgebungsverfahren,
sondern nur so eben Anträge. Wie waren die?
Genau, beim letzten Beispiel, das war jetzt in diesem Sommer,
da war das auch auf Antrag der Oppositionsfraktion.
Das ging rund um das Thema Datenschutz und ich versuche es jetzt mal neutral
zu formulieren, inwieweit es ein Spannungsfeld zwischen Datenschutz und Innovation gibt.
Und die Meinungsbeiträge fielen da durchaus auch unterschiedlich aus.
Da war eben nicht nur Zivilgesellschaft da, sondern da hat Simone gerade schon
gesagt, da sind ja eine ganze Reihe von Sachverständigen aus unterschiedlichen
Bereichen, die dann eben auch unterschiedlicher Sachen von sich bringen.
Aber hatten die einen bestimmten Zweck? Also Simone hat jetzt zum Beispiel ein
bestimmtes Ziel. Der Bundestag wolle irgendwas beschließen. War das bei dir auch so?
Es war vage. Das war auch relativ kurze Zeit nach der Anhörung zur Novellierung
des Bundesdatenschutzgesetzes, die ja vielleicht auch einige verfolgt haben,
wo der CCC ja auch vertreten war mit einem Experten.
Und ja, insofern war das so ein bisschen eine gedoppelte Diskussion aus einer
anderen Richtung kommend, sag ich mal.
Okay, jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen beschrieben, wie die Situation ungefähr
ist, aber jetzt müssen wir vielleicht mal ein bisschen darauf kommen,
wie das im gesamten Prozess dieses Raumschiffs-Bundestag so läuft.
Wir können aber später nochmal ein bisschen in die Landtage kommen.
Wir haben Ausschüsse, das haben wir schon in anderen Folgen von Dicke Bretter
besprochen, die sich bestimmten Themen widmen.
Bei dir eben der Innenausschuss, im Wesentlichen ist es ja also die Gesetzgebung
für zum Beispiel die Polizei, aber auch für die Geheimdienste.
Gut, der Innenausschuss macht glaube ich auch noch Sport und so,
also die haben noch andere Themen, also im Prinzip die Zuschneidung des Ministeriums
und bei dir waren es ja Ausschüsse, die teilweise übergreifende Themen haben,
also die nicht gesetzgebend sind, sondern
zum Beispiel mehrere Ministerien betreffen können und so.
Aber der eigentliche Hintergrund von einer Sachverständigen Anhörung ist ja
zunächst mal ein Erkenntnisinteresse.
Man möchte Experten zusammenholen und
die juristischen, aber auch andere Einschätzungen dazu hören.
Würdest du erstmal im Grundsatz sagen, ich frage dich mal, weil du ja sozusagen
gerade aus Anhörungen kommst, Simone, würdest du sagen, dass das im Grundsatz auch so läuft?
Haben die ein Erkenntnisinteresse und hast du den Eindruck gehabt,
dass du als Expertin da mitwirkst an dieser politischen Meinungsbildung?
Im Grundsatz hatte ich schon das Gefühl, dass es gerade darin besteht und deswegen
ist es ja auch ein großes Privileg.
Ich glaube, das ist schon die eine Chance, die man in dem, also nicht nur die
eine, Es gibt ja auch noch so Verbändebeteiligung ein bisschen vorher, aber in der Regel.
Aber eine große Chance, in der man die eigenen Argumente und die eigene Sichtweise
darstellen kann und dadurch natürlich auch, dadurch, dass es öffentlich ist,
auch einfach viel Aufmerksamkeit auf die eigenen Argumente entdecken kann,
das ist vielleicht so ein bisschen noch der zweite Aspekt.
Und ja, also ich hatte schon den Eindruck, dass es viel um Sachkunde einbringen
geht, weil Abgeordnete halt gerade jetzt keine ExpertInnen-Kommission oder so
darstellen und das ja vielleicht auch nicht in dem Ausmaß immer abbilden können,
Arbeitsgruppen und so weiter.
Nur ist es ja so, in deinem Fall, wenn wir jetzt nochmal über das Beispiel Palantir
reden, also Innenausschuss, Antrag der Opposition, ist Palantir schon relativ,
würde man sagen, ein Nischenthema.
Das heißt, es gibt nicht so viele Experten bundesweit, die sich intensiv damit
beschäftigen, du gehörst zu denen.
Trotzdem ist es ja so, eigentlich könnte man, wenn man wollte,
ja, verschiedene Experten, die sich erst einarbeiten oder so in dieses Thema
einladen. Wie und wer hat dich denn angesprochen als Expertin,
die sich speziell mit Palantir beschäftigt?
Also die offizielle Einladung bekommt man natürlich immer über den Ausschuss,
aber grundsätzlich wird man von den Fraktionen vorgeschlagen.
Die können Sachverständige benennen, die dann eingeladen werden sollen.
In dem Fall wurde ich von den Grünen eingeladen.
Also von der Regierung, wenn man so will. Wir sind nämlich gerade,
habe ich noch nicht gesagt, wir sind im Jahr 2024 und das regiert Rot,
Grün und Gelb unter Kanzler Olaf Scholz.
Wer weiß, wann dieser Podcast von irgendjemand gehört wird.
Also du bist von der Regierungsseite eingeladen worden. War das bei dir auch so?
Genau, bei mir war es aber die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion, die mich eingeladen hat.
Ist jemand von euch jemals von der Opposition eingeladen worden?
Auf jeden Fall. Und zwar war das bei mir das erste Mal, dass ich von einer Regierende
Fraktion eingeladen wurde.
Vorher war es tatsächlich oft die Linke, die, glaube ich, schon versucht haben,
da zivilgesellschaftliche Stimmen mit reinzuholen.
Ihr wisst vielleicht, oder wenn ich sage, ich sage es auch den Hörern,
die Linke hat ja den Fraktionsstatus verloren und sie können in den meisten
Ausschüssen keine Sachverständigen mehr berufen.
Mir ist das doch schon selber passiert. Ich war als Sachverständige vorgesehen,
aber dann verlor sich dieser Fraktionsstatus durch die Abtrennung der BSW sozusagen.
Also es ist das BSW, ja das Bündnis.
Und seitdem können die keine Sachverständigen benennen und die anderen Parteien
haben sich auch nicht zu kompromissenbereit erklärt, weil die eben keine Fraktion mehr sind. Aha.
Macht es einen Unterschied, wenn man sozusagen regierungsseitig berufen ist?
Oder würdest du sagen, dass es einen Unterschied macht, Simona?
Also ich habe persönlich da als wenig Unterschied gemerkt, glaube ich.
So ein bisschen natürlich dann die Anzahl der Fragen, die man im Zweifel dann
auch bekommt, macht natürlich was aus.
Also zum Beispiel die Linke kann jetzt auch in den Sachverständigenanhörungen
einfach gar nicht mehr wirklich viele Fragen stellen.
Das ist natürlich schon auch einfach total schade, würde ich sagen,
weil da natürlich dann auch nochmal vielleicht kritische Nachfragen einfach verloren gehen.
Ich glaube, das kann man schon anmerken.
Vielleicht habt ihr da ja auch Erfahrungen.
Wir haben dann noch nicht so ganz, du hast am Anfang erwähnt,
du hast dieses Eingangsstatement und dann gibt es eine Form von Dialog.
Vielleicht würdest du irgendwann sagen, in deinem Fall, weil es im Innenausschuss
immer ein bisschen strikt gehandhabt wird, wie läuft es denn danach weiter?
Also du hast dieses Eingangsstatement, sind wir eine Menge Sachverständigen
und dann gibt es ja diese Fragerunde, wie läuft die praktisch?
Genau, da geht man eigentlich Reihe um. Und dann gibt es, glaube ich,
also ich glaube, das ist immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich.
Bei mir gab es, glaube ich, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, dann pro Fraktion
zwei Fragen in den ersten beiden Runden.
Und dann hat man noch so eine schnelle Runde am Schluss, glaube ich, mit einer gemacht.
Die ist auch zeitlich begrenzt. Also um die Frage zu stellen,
da ist man ein bisschen aufwärtig, dass dann irgendwie super viele Fragen in
eine Frage reingedrückt werden.
Und man aber dann trotzdem als Sachverständige Person trotzdem halt nur diese
zwei Minuten Zeit hat, um zu antworten.
Also quasi einmal so ein Rundumlauf durch die Fraktion und wenn man einmal durch
ist, fängt es wieder von vorne an und man schaut so ein bisschen,
wie viel Zeit hat man denn jetzt eigentlich noch.
Und man weiß ja vorher, also es gibt ja sozusagen einen abgemachten Zeitrahmen,
in dem man da diese Sachverständigenanhörung durchführt. Also man weiß ja,
wo das Ende ist und das wird auch eingehalten.
Also zumindest im Innenausschuss ist das relativ strikt, ne?
Sehr strikt, ja.
Also das liegt natürlich auch am Bundestag an sich. Ich meine,
da ist halt immer sehr viel Arbeit. Also anders als vielleicht viele Menschen
denken, sind die Abgeordneten mit sehr, sehr vielen Aufgaben konfrontiert und
haben immer einen echten Fahrplan am Tag.
Also die ziehen eigentlich auch nicht fünf Minuten über, das ist jetzt meine Erfahrung.
Hatte ich auch den Eindruck.
Jetzt frage ich aber mal, Elisa, war das auch so, dass in dieser Fragerunde,
in deiner letzten Anhörung, wo vielleicht nicht an so strikt wie im Innenausschuss
läuft, war da mehr Dialog oder war das dann auch so sehr aufgeteilt nach Fraktionen?
Also ich teile jetzt einfach mal meine anekdotische Erfahrung, die ich so gemacht habe.
Wie Simone schon gesagt hat, werden wir ja von einer bestimmten Fraktion eingeladen.
Das heißt, das ist auch öffentlich, also das wird heute zumindest auch in der
ExpertInnen-Liste, in der Sachverständigenliste mit so einer Fußnote markiert,
von welcher Fraktion man eingeladen wurde.
Und die Fragen, die man dann in dieser zweiten Runde kriegt,
die kommt eigentlich nur von der Fraktion, die einen eingeladen hat.
Also das ist insofern echt keine Diskussion. Das habe ich zumindest noch nicht
erlebt, dass da wirklich ein Standpunkt rausgearbeitet wurde oder so.
Also das ist kein Diskurs.
Es gibt eine Fraktion, die strukturell Probleme hat, Sachverständige zu kriegen
aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen und das ist die AfD.
Die fragen dann manchmal gar nichts und manchmal fragen sie irgendwelche anderen Sachverständigen.
Darauf reagieren Leute dann sehr unterschiedlich. Manche antworten,
manche verweigern die Antwort, manche beziehen auch konkret Stellung,
dass sie der AfD-Bundestagsfraktion keine Antwort geben wollen.
Wie das letztens die großartige Adine Blankertz von Wikimedia gemacht hat.
Das ist also sehr unterschiedlich. Das heißt aber, ja, also Diskussionen,
ich glaube, den Namen verdient es nicht.
Okay. Hast du das auch so erlebt, Simone? Wie war das bei dir bei der AfD?
Da war ja ein Sachverständiger in deinem letzten Fall jetzt.
Du hast ja mehr Erfahrung, aber in dieser Pallantier beispielsweise hast du ja einen
Jurist für die AfD da, ne?
Ja, also, die haben mich quasi in Ruhe gelassen. Ist ja schon nochmal das,
was man so vorher so ein bisschen mitbekommt.
Auch aus anderen Erfahrungen so, dass man sich so ein bisschen vorbereitet,
was macht man dann eigentlich?
Genau, aber mein Eindruck war derselbe. Also man bekommt die Fragen von der
Fraktion gestellt, die einen auch benannt hat.
Ich finde, es gibt noch so eine neutrale Instanz quasi ein bisschen,
an die dann auch Fragen gerichtet wurden.
Wurden jetzt jedenfalls in meinen Anhörungen, nämlich der Bundesbeauftragte
für den Datenschutz und die Informationsfreiheit, der wird dann auch noch mit
einbezogen, so von allen Fraktionen, aber sonst ist es schon sehr, sehr zugeschnitten
auf die jeweiligen eigenen Sachverständigen sozusagen.
Man kann vielleicht dazu sagen, das ist also Ulrich Kelber noch gewesen,
in diesem speziellen Fall gibt er jetzt eine Nachfolgerin, aber wenn ich meine
Erfahrungen einbringen würde, würde ich sagen, dass Kelber sehr wenig gefragt worden ist.
Es gibt tatsächlich, oder zumindest in den Anhörungen, die ich so mitgemacht
habe über die Jahre, auch Anhörungen, wo die damalige Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte
oder der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte extrem dominierend waren,
also sehr stark eingebunden wurde.
Und hier in dem Palantierfall hat er eigentlich nur zwei Statements gemacht,
also es war eigentlich relativ wenig. Das heißt, es hängt immer ein bisschen
thematisch damit zusammen, wer eigentlich jetzt wie befragt wird.
Das muss ich jetzt kurz einbringen. Es war nicht immer so.
Ich bin ja schon ein bisschen länger in diesem Sachverständigen-Business und
früher war das dialogischer. Und vor allen Dingen bei Themen,
die neu waren technisch, war das so, dass über die Fraktionen hinweg gefragt
wurde und Erkenntnisinteresse da war.
Leider beobachte ich tatsächlich genau wie ihr in den letzten Jahren überhaupt nicht mehr.
Es wird also starrer, auch diese Tatsache, dass die Fraktionen immer nur die
befragen oder fast nur die befragen, die sie auch eingeladen haben als Sachverständige.
Das ist ein neueres Phänomen und ich finde es auch nicht gut.
Wie erklärst du dir das denn? Hast du da eine Hypothese?
Wissen Sie alles? Haben Sie keinen Erkenntnisgewinn mehr? Haben Sie alle Fragen
zum Technischen gestellt, die Sie stellen wollen?
Das eine ist, ich habe den Eindruck, es ist sehr beschleunigt jetzt im Bundestag.
Also wir haben jetzt ja noch nicht so ein bisschen darüber gesprochen,
wie es in anderen Ausschüssen ist, wo man einen Referentenentwurf oder einen
Gesetzesentwurf hat, über den man ganz sehr konkret spricht.
Aber mein Eindruck ist, es ist einfach ein hoher zeitlicher Druck da.
Und ich empfinde die Sachverständigenanhörung zumindest teilweise als Simulation von Beteiligung.
Also mehr als früher. Ich fand das manchmal schon früher frustrierend,
aber zumindest, also ich war immer natürlich als Techniker eingeladen, das ist mein Beruf und
vielleicht sind viele technische Gegebenheiten mittlerweile bekannt,
da kann man nicht mehr so viel lernen als Abgeordneter.
Die Zeit, wo der Bundestag irgendwie die Technik als Neuland betrachtet,
ist vorbei. Insofern, vielleicht hat sich da auch was getan.
Für mich ist es schwierig zu sagen, also ich habe auch oft frustrierende Momente
erlebt, aber auch das Gegenteil in all den Jahren.
Deswegen würde ich euch gerne mal fragen, jetzt haben wir so ein bisschen den
Bundestag besprochen, ja,
Die Zivilgesellschaft ist beteiligt, die Akademie ist in hohem Maß beteiligt.
In der Regel sind immer mehrere, gerade bei den Juristen, Professoren anwesend.
Es gibt noch die Verbände, die
klassischen, in der Regel Wirtschaftsverbände, die da auch noch sitzen.
Aber wie ist es denn im Vergleich dazu, da wart ihr ja nun auch schon in den
Landtagen. Was würdet ihr sagen? Fang mal an, Simone.
Ja, ich war einmal im Bayerischen Landtag. Es war viel weniger formalisiert.
Es gab zwar schon grundsätzlich auch eine Zeitbeschränkung, so insgesamt,
wie lang es dauern soll. Die hat man dann aber schon auch einfach gut überzogen.
Das war auch nicht so problematisch.
Und es war schon sehr viel mehr Diskussion. Also man hatte zum Beispiel,
also Eingangsstatement war schon sehr viel länger.
Da gab es dann auch so eine Pi mal Daumen Beschränkung und vielleicht nicht
unbedingt darüber gehen jetzt. Aber ich glaube, da hatte man,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, vielleicht sogar zehn Minuten oder so.
Oder vielleicht waren es noch fünf. Aber genau, also schon um einiges länger.
Und da wurde auch nicht so strikt auf die Zeit geguckt.
Bei Fragen konnte man sich grundsätzlich auch ein bisschen selbst einschalten.
Man konnte auch so erwidern darauf, was andere Sachverständige gesagt hatten.
Das fand ich eigentlich schon auch gewinnbringend, weil man ja dann oft vielleicht
auch mein Argument hört und man sich denkt, Okay, da habe ich wirklich ein sehr
gutes Gegenargument und das natürlich in diesem streng formalen Prozess einfach
überhaupt nicht unterbringen kann dann.
Ja, da war am Ende letztlich wirklich mehr Diskussion und auch die Abgeordneten
haben oft auch Fragen an mehrere Sachverständige gerichtet und nicht ausschließlich
an, also Tendenz schon auch in die Richtung, aber nicht ausschließlich.
Und manchmal dann auch so ein bisschen berufsgruppenübergreifende Fragestellungen.
Okay, würdest du zustimmen oder hast du andere Erfahrungen gemacht, Elisa?
Nee, das war bei mir ähnlich. Ich war in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Das war im ersten Jahr der Pandemie.
Das heißt, das war eine digitale Zuschaltung. Das war damals,
glaube ich, auch noch so ein bisschen neu. Und vielleicht waren wir da auch
alle sehr achtsam miteinander.
Ich fand das Gesprächsklima einfach sehr nett. Ich weiß nicht,
ob das jetzt den äußeren Umständen geschuldet war oder ob das einfach so die gelebte Kultur ist.
Und das Thema war auch eigentlich ein ganz spannendes, nachdem ja zu Beginn
der Pandemie ganz viele Vereine wie Freifunk und viele andere so reingegangen
sind und grundlegende Infrastrukturen für Schulen, aber auch für Arztpraxen
und so weiter bereitgestellt haben.
Da hat sich ja in der Politik zu Recht die Frage gestellt, okay,
wie können wir eigentlich dieses digitale Engagement, das digitale Ehrenamt
besser unterstützen und genau das war Thema der Anhörung.
Und ich fand, das war eine sehr wertschätzende und sehr gute Diskussion und
tatsächlich auch eine Diskussion, die ihren Namen verdient.
Ich habe ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht. Also ich war auch schon in Bayern und
ich kann mich an NRW und an Hessen erinnern.
Also ich habe eine Zeit lang auch Landtage als Sachverständige beraten.
Ich habe es auch immer als ein bisschen weniger eitel und einfach auch mehr
sachorientiert empfunden und weniger als Korsett, weil so diese zeitlichen Beschränkungen bestimmt.
Aber ich habe auch Ausnahmen erlebt. Also es gab in Hessen mal eine ganz große
Sachverständigenanhörung, wo ich als Sachverständige mit dabei war.
Da waren wirklich also 40 Leute oder so, dann wird es natürlich auch ein bisschen
harscher, weil man einfach, man muss die ja auch domptieren in gewisser Weise,
damit nicht alle durcheinander reden.
Insofern ein bisschen hängt es zumindest aus meiner Erfahrung auch mit der Größe zusammen.
Aber im Bundestag, das haben wir vielleicht noch gar nicht so erwähnt,
ist es natürlich auch irgendwie beschränkt, denn die Anzahl der Sachverständigen
im Bundestag ist eigentlich immer gleich, nämlich an den Fraktionen und dann
noch die zusätzlichen Verbände orientiert.
Also ich habe selten an den Präsidenten mehr als acht oder neun waren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr andere Erfahrungen gemacht habt, aber so sieben oder
acht ist eigentlich der Standard, oder? Ja, war ich auch so.
Dann wollen wir vielleicht mal zu dem anderen Teil kommen.
Wie ist es denn, wenn man jetzt einen konkreten Gesetzentwurf vor der Nase hat,
dann hat man ja jetzt nicht so,
wenn man ja eigentlich konkrete Kritik anbringt,
insbesondere von Juristen, an dem, was da aufgeschrieben ist und möglicherweise
aufzeigen, an welchen Stellen das rechtswidrig ist oder unsinnig oder wo vielleicht
definitorisch nachgearbeitet werden muss. Also nur Dinge.
Wie würdest du sozusagen den Unterschied, ich frage dich jetzt mal gleich,
Simone, sehen bei diesem typischen Gesetzesentwurf oder Referentenentwurf Anhörungen?
Ja, ich glaube, da gilt und vielleicht sind da dann auch noch mal mehr JuristInnen irgendwie dabei.
Es geht auch viel darum, so rechtliche Grenzen zu markieren,
während man, glaube ich, in diesen eher offen formulierten Anträgen und so weiter
einfach ein bisschen mehr Raum für politische Forderungen und Argumentationen
hat und da auch gar nicht so gezwungen ist, auf rechtliche Grenzen einzugehen.
Jetzt ist es ja bei der GFF so, dass wir auf der einen Seite natürlich sehr
viele JuristInnen sind, die die rechtlichen Grenzen dann schon kennen,
aber natürlich darüber hinaus trotzdem politische Forderungen haben.
Und insofern ist es für uns eigentlich immer eine gute Chance,
um auch die da reinzubringen und gleichzeitig so ein bisschen zu markieren, wo Grenzen liegen.
Aber das ist natürlich dann schon auch einiges an Aufwand, ehrlich gesagt,
weil man sich Gesetzentwürfe dann ja, die können ja auch einfach unfassbar lang sein.
Die Zeit ist beschränkt, da kommen wir vielleicht auch noch drauf später,
in der man die dann intern erstmal bewertet, sodass man so ein bisschen selbst
für sich erstmal auch in der Vorbereitung so einen Fokus finden muss.
Und dann natürlich nochmal, weil auch dann der Vortrag ist ja wieder relativ
kurz, sich gut überlegen muss, wo genau greift man jetzt an und wo fordert man
nochmal was und Nachbesserungen.
Und im besten Fall hat man natürlich immer vielleicht auch gleich irgendwie
eine Formulierung parat, wie man es irgendwie besser machen könnte.
Genau, das war so ein bisschen meine Erfahrung dazu.
Das heißt, du warst in einer Anhörung, wo ein konkreter Gesetzentwurf besprochen
wurde. Was für ein Gesetzentwurf war das?
Genau, da ging es um das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz und da haben wir aber den Fokus
ein bisschen weggelegt in unserer Stellungnahme von den konkret vorgeschlagenen Regeln.
Also da hatten wir uns auch, die haben wir uns natürlich angeschaut und da auch
einiges zu kritisieren gehabt. Haben aber dann noch darüber hinaus vorgeschlagen, noch mehr aufzunehmen.
Und zwar ging es da eben auch um biometrische Fernidentifikation und ein Verbot,
das man mit aufnehmen könnte, als eine Art Vorschlag, die wir da platzieren wollten.
Dann geht ja auch nicht immer nur um den konkreten Inhalt der Gesetze,
sondern auch, was fehlt, was ist nicht geregelt oder was wünscht man sich.
Aber ich will mal noch mal ganz grundsätzlicher fragen. Also du bist nicht jeder Jurist irgendwie.
Sag mal, wie du vorgehst. Also du kriegst diesen Gesetzentwurf von Latz,
du weißt, du hast irgendwie drei Wochen und dann ist diese Anhörung,
das ist ja oftmals zeitlich ziemlich eng.
Sag mal ungefähr, wie du vorgehst. Du wirst ja wahrscheinlich bestimmte Themen,
die dich schon vorher an dieser gesetzlichen Regelung interessieren.
Wie gehst du vor? Was versuchst du zu tun mit dem Entwurf?
Ja, im besten Fall hat man ja vorher schon so ein bisschen mitbekommen,
worum es geht und konnte sich auf jeden Fall da schon ein paar Argumente irgendwie
im Laufe der Zeit auch zurechtlegen.
Jetzt hat man natürlich was sehr Konkretes. Dann ist natürlich ein bisschen
die Frage auch erstmal, wer arbeitet intern dazu? Dazu gibt es irgendwie intern
und auch andere NGOs zum Beispiel, die Meinungen und Argumente haben,
die man noch einbinden will.
Und das sollte, glaube ich, schon immer irgendwie auch im Fokus sein.
Das heißt erstmal sehr viel Austausch dazu. Dann natürlich muss man ganz konkret
in die Regelungen reingehen.
Relativ schnell finde ich aber so ein bisschen aus, sondern wo macht es Sinn,
sich viel mit zu beschäftigen?
Wo liegen eigentlich unsere Themen? Und womit können wir uns jedenfalls nicht
beschäftigen, weil die Zeit drängt und weil wir dazu gar nicht so wirklich arbeiten.
Und dann geht es als nächsten Schritt darum, gerade in die Normen oder auch
in das, was fehlt, nochmal mehr einzusteigen und einmal eine rechtliche Prüfung
irgendwie vorzunehmen.
Also für uns bedeutet das viel Abgleich auch mit Verfassungsrechtsprechung dann
und gleichzeitig uns aber auch immer überlegen, was für Argumente sprechen auch dafür,
dass man die Grenzen nicht unbedingt immer ausreizen muss, sondern dass man
vielleicht auch einfach mal so ein bisschen weiter weg von Grenzen geht und
nicht immer so versucht,
gerade dahin zu kommen mit Gesetzgebung, die insbesondere Überwachungsbefugnisse
betrifft, dass man im Zweifel wieder vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht landet.
Und da haben wir natürlich einen kleinen Vorteil als Sachverständige,
weil vielleicht immer so eine kleine Drohung mitschwingen könnte.
Nein, also das ist jetzt ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert,
aber wir klagen ja dann einfach auch gegen die Gesetze, die wir für nicht verfassungskonform
am Ende halten, versuchen die natürlich aber vorzubeugen, indem wir gleich in
so Sachverständigenanhörungen unsere Argumente immer vortragen.
Das ist ja sehr häufig so. Also tatsächlich, die Verfassungsbeschwerden der
letzten zehn Jahre kann man sich durchsehen und vieles davon ist in Sachverständigenanführung
genau so schon genannt worden. Ja, gar keine Frage.
Und nicht nur sozusagen von Sachverständigen von der GFF, die sich speziell
auf diese strategischen Verfassungsbeschwerden auch kaprizieren,
sondern natürlich auch von Juristen, die an irgendwelchen Lehrstühlen arbeiten
und genau dort auch herausarbeiten. Ihr seid ja nicht die Einzigen.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ja, jetzt hat Simone gerade erzählt, so ein bisschen wie das bei Gesetzgebungen
aussieht und das ist ja auch der Grund dafür, warum immer so viele Juristen
da sind, natürlich, wenn man das auch juristisch bewerten will.
Aber eigentlich, wenn man jetzt mal so ein bisschen auf den Zweck von Sachverständigenanhörungen
schaut, ist es ja nur bei den gesetzgebenden Ausschüssen so.
Warum sind eigentlich auch sonst immer so viele Juristen da?
Es gibt ja viele Wissenschaften, die sich auseinandersetzen mit Regelungen.
Sind ja nicht nur die Techies oder so.
Wieso ist eigentlich die Rüstenquote so hoch?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Wahrscheinlich auch meine Antwort mehr Spekulation.
Man könnte jetzt auch meinen, gut, wenn es darum geht, so rechtliche Grenzen
zu markieren, reicht irgendwie eine Person aus dem Bereich.
Aber dann ist natürlich so, dass es auch gerade in dem Bereich tausend Meinungen gibt.
Deswegen, ich könnte mir wirklich vorstellen, dass man damit einfach oft einfach
so Expertise haben will, wie weit kann man gehen, wie weit kann man nicht gehen.
Aber das ist natürlich dann schon ein Problem. Die Zielrichtung einer Anhörung
kann ja auch eine andere sein.
Das ist ja nicht immer die Frage, wo sind rechtliche Grenzen,
sondern geht ja auch eigentlich viel drum oder sollte im besten Fall so sein,
andere ExpertInnen, betroffenen Perspektiven und so weiter einzubeziehen, um,
und das können JuristInnen glaube ich einfach nicht so gut abbilden,
einmal zu zeigen, was ist denn überhaupt als Mittel so geeignet,
um ein Problem anzugehen und nicht, wo liegt die Grenze, was man machen darf irgendwie.
Man kommt dann in eine andere Denke, wenn man immer nur diese rechtlichen Schranken betrachtet.
Wie war denn bei deinen Anhörungen? Da war jetzt ja nicht unbedingt ein konkreter
Entwurf, an dem ihr euch abgearbeitet habt. Waren da auch so viele Juristen oder wie war das?
Nee, also ich meine, ein Jurist, der da war, war Max Schrems,
was bei Datenschutz auch inhaltlich total viel Sinn ergibt.
Ich sollte mal kurz sagen, wer das ist. Das ist ein Österreicher,
der wirklich viele strategische Datenschutzklagen europaweit angestrengt hat.
Er hat mittlerweile einen eigenen Verein gegründet und ist wirklich ein juristischer
Aktivist und zwar ein sehr erfolgreicher. Mehrere EuGH-Urteile. Genau.
Und ich meine, er ist so zentral in der Datenschutzdebatte, dass es verschiedene
Urteile Schrems 1 und 2 gibt. Das heißt, Max Schrems hat in dieser Anhörung
über die Urteile Schrems 1 und 2 gesprochen.
Also es war sehr lustig, es war sehr rekursiv alles irgendwie.
Das heißt aber, wir hatten da tatsächlich natürlich juristische Expertise.
Es war aber konkret, weil das Thema jetzt in der letzten Anhörung ja diese ominöse
Innovation und Datenschutzdebatte war, war natürlich auch viel Wirtschaft anwesend.
Die alle gehemmt werden durch den Datenschutz.
Genau, also Bitkom war nachhaltig gehemmt durch, nein, die waren eigentlich
auch ganz differenziert, aber das war so ein bisschen wie soll ich sagen,
die Wirtschaft, die Aussagen der Wirtschaft, da waren drei VertreterInnen, ja genau,
die waren auf einem Spektrum von ja, da ist Verbesserungsbedarf bis hin zu,
wir sind kurz vor den wirtschaftlichen Ruinen, weil der Datenschutz da uns also
komplett auf Abstellgleis geschoben hat und das war ganz interessant zu hören,
aber das waren natürlich keine juristischen Argumente mehr, das waren dann irgendwie Studien,
Mittelstandsbefragung und solche Fakten, die herangezogen wurden.
Hast du für diese Art Ausschüsse, also wenn man da ein Thema bespricht und eine
Meinung bilden will, eine politische und auch eine inhaltliche Meinung,
hast du da auch schriftliche Stellungnahmen abgegeben?
Ja, genau. Habe ich auch. Aufgrund der Zeit allerdings recht kurze,
und Simone, du hattest das vorher schon gesagt, man kriegt vorher so ein einen Fragenkatalog,
wo also die Fraktionen alle Fragen mit reingeben und wird dann aufgefordert,
diese Fragen zu beantworten und das ist in der Regel eine Bandbreite,
die wahrscheinlich die Expertise jeder einzelnen Person übersteigt,
weil die einfach so breit sind und dann hast du auch schon gesagt,
man muss sich irgendwie auch strategisch
überlegen, was sind denn die Schwerpunkte, die ich setzen will,
was sind die Sachen, wo ich auch aus meiner Kompetenz heraus,
wirklich was beitragen kann und auch absehen kann, dass das jetzt die wirklich
wichtigen Veränderungen sind und das heißt auch, dass dass in der schriftlichen
Stellungnahme, da gibt es unterschiedliche Strategien, damit umzugehen.
Manche listen in ihren schriftlichen Stellungnahmen Frage 1 auf und sagen dann
hier nehme ich nicht Stellung und dann bei Frage 2 schreiben sie 3D in der 4 Seiten,
während andere eher eine Art von Einschätzung zum Gesamtthema schreiben und
dann referenzieren, welche Fragen sie wo irgendwie so ein bisschen versteckt beantworten.
Also auch das wiederum, unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen, ist glaube ich am
Ende auch eine Kapazitätenfrage.
Vielleicht dazu noch ergänzend zu den Fragenkatalogen, also gibt es ja nicht immer, also manchmal,
oft dann vielleicht auch bei so Selbstbefassung zu einem bestimmten großen Thema,
dass es vielleicht doch strukturierter ist und dadurch natürlich aber trotzdem
eine abartige Masse erzeugt, aber gleichzeitig bei den zwei Sachverständigenanhörungen
im Bundestag, bei denen ich war, gab es keinen Fragenkatalog dazu.
Dazu, dann ist man natürlich deutlich freier nochmal, was man,
also man kriegt das natürlich auch immer unter eine Frage dann rein irgendwie,
aber man ist so ein bisschen freier, was man da vortragen kann.
In Bayern hingegen gab es auch einen wirklich extrem umfassenden Fragenkatalog
und da hatte ich den ähnlichen Eindruck wie du und habe dann auch einfach aussortiert
ein bisschen und die anderen Sachverständigen machen das ja auch so.
Glaubst du, dass die Entscheidung, ob es einen Fragenkatalog gibt oder nicht,
davon abhängt, Und ob es einen Gesetzesentwurfstext gibt, weil in dem einen
Beispiel gab es ja keinen.
Also quasi woran entscheidet sich, ob ein Fragenkatalog zusammengestellt wird oder nicht?
Ich habe es auch unterschiedlich erlebt. Ich habe lange Kataloge erlebt und
auch Anhörungen, wo gar keine einzige Frage formuliert war.
Ich weiß nicht, also soweit ich weiß, gibt es keine gesetzliche Regelung oder
so, sondern ich denke, es liegt auch ein bisschen daran, wie sich die Ausschüsse,
wie die zusammenarbeiten, wie die sich konstituieren.
Es gibt ja diese Obleuterrunde, das kennt ihr sicher. dass eine bestimmte Person
aus jeder Fraktion sich dann mit der Vorsitzenden oder dem Vorsitzenden abstimmt.
Ich denke, es wird einfach, wie die sich selber ihre Aufgaben geben,
zusammenhängen. Ich wüsste nicht, was Regeln gibt.
Ich konnte jedenfalls keinen Pattern entdecken über die Jahre.
Waren das Fragenkataloge und wie lange gibt man schon? Waren die elend lang?
Ich könnte es auch nicht sagen. Ich würde euch aber gerne nochmal eine andere
Frage stellen, wo wir jetzt ein bisschen über wir haben über die Juristen geredet
und über die Stellungnahmen.
Mir fällt, ich habe auch schon sehr viele Anhörungen einfach,
seit es möglich ist, live angeguckt, einfach darüber, was mich inhaltlich interessiert
oder was ich darüber schreiben will oder so.
Da sind ja einige weniger Frauen. Da sind schon immer noch Männer dominierte
Sachverständige anhörend, ist meine Erfahrung, insbesondere bei der Jurisprudenz.
Aber auch sonst, unter den Technics war ich auch oft die einzige Frau.
Hattet ihr jemals den Eindruck, da als Frau, zumal als jüngere Frau,
irgendwie anders behandelt zu werden?
Also habt ihr Sachen, positiv oder negativ, also entgegenkommt oder aber auch
hochabwertend. Habt ihr da irgendwelche Erfahrungen gemacht?
Also ich teile deinen Eindruck jedenfalls insgesamt so, was die Diversitätsfrage
für den Innenausschuss und die Sachverständigenanhörungen, in denen ich war, auf jeden Fall angeht.
Ich hatte persönlich gar keine negative Erfahrung.
Aber auch keine positive?
Doch, ehrlich gesagt, das fand ich eigentlich ganz witzig, so in Bayern wurde
das nochmal so besonders herausgestellt.
Da wurde ich dann auch einfach immer mit Frau Doktor angesprochen.
Das war irgendwie lustig.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Aber sonst hatte ich keine negativen Erfahrungen. Ich glaube,
es gibt schon so, was man so hört.
Auch andere Menschen haben negative Erfahrungen gemacht.
Ja, okay. Aber du könntest konkret, das ist doch gut. Das ist eigentlich eine
schöne Sache. War das bei dir, Elisa?
Ja, das war bei einer Einladung, die ich mal bekommen hatte.
Da wurde ich so vorgewarnt, ein bisschen ominös.
Ja, mach dich mal drauf gefasst, dass wenn du sprichst, es gibt so ein paar
Kandidaten in der Runde, also unter den Abgeordneten jetzt, die dann laut anfangen
zu sprechen oder lachen, wenn du redest und so. Und dann dachte ich,
das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Ich habe gesagt, das ist so ein Kindergarten. Aber Bundestag oder Landtag? Er war Bundestag.
Und ich hatte das dann mir angehört und dachte mir, so benimmt sich doch kein Mensch. Fakt ist doch.
Und ich meine, ehrlich gesagt, ich fand das anthropologisch total spannend und
habe mich innerlich ein bisschen kaputt gelacht und habe dann von einer Person
irgendwie auch noch eine Frage gestellt bekommen tatsächlich,
die so ein bisschen antagonistisch sein sollte. Auf die hatte ich in meiner
Stellungnahme aber schon Bezug genommen.
Da kannst du diesen einfachen Punkt machen, zu sagen, wie ich in meinem Vortrag
gerade schon gesagt habe.
Die Frage war, sie haben halt nicht zugehört. Das ist ein bisschen...
Unwürdig? Also ich fand es jetzt nicht dramatisch, aber ich fand es,
ja, respektlos, unwürdig, glaube ich.
Ja, die sind im Hohen Hause, das ist ja immerhin noch nicht mehr unsere Volksvertretung.
Was ist denn ihr Job? Also ich meine, ihr Job ist es da zu sitzen und irgendwie
sich die Expertisen anzuhören und wenn sie das nicht schaffen,
für drei Minuten, meine Güte.
Sie können ja auch rausgehen, da gibt es ja keine Anwesenheit.
Na gut, aber das hat vielleicht auch eher damit zu tun, von welcher Fraktion
du benannt wirst oder so. Also vielleicht auch einfach persönliche,
wie soll ich mal sagen, Eigenschaften von Menschen, die eben Abgeordneten sind.
Und wenn die vielleicht ein bisschen respektlose Persönlichkeiten sind,
charakterliche Schwächen haben, dann nicht wahr?
Ich habe durchaus auch sehr unangenehme Situationen in all den Jahren erlebt.
Vor allen Dingen, als die AfD neu war im Bundestag.
Damals war das ja ein großer Streit um den Rechtsausschuss. Ich war mehrfach
im Rechtsausschuss und da war ja auch der AfDler, der Vorsitzende.
Und ich bin da arg aneinandergeraten mit diesen AfDlern, die mich immer,
wenn ich fort wäre, Fräulein nannten und so.
Aber, also, ne, also ich bin jetzt nicht auf dem Mund gefallen,
ich hab denen auch gesagt, dass ich so nicht mehr genannt werden müsste und
wie ich von denen genannt werden möchte, aber das ist mir passiert.
Aber ich kann jetzt auch nicht sagen, das hat mir jetzt großartig passiert,
wer als Frau, sondern eher, weil ich von einer bestimmten Fraktion da eingeladen wurde.
Also ich war bisher immer nur sozusagen von der Opposition eingeladen,
egal jetzt in den verschiedenen Regierungen und ich hatte eh den Enoch damit zu tun.
Konstantin, jetzt bist du ja am längsten
von uns dreien hier schon in unterschiedlichen Ausschüssen gewesen.
Im Sachverständigen-Business. Im Sachverständigen-Business, als Sachverständigen-Großverdienerin.
Aber hast du das Gefühl, da verändert sich auch was, so von dem Klima her,
von der Gesprächskultur her? Also hast du das Gefühl, es wird besser?
Nee, ich kann nicht sagen, dass ich in Erinnerung habe, dass es besser wird.
Zum einen, mein Eindruck ist, dass die Fristen sehr viel knapper sind.
Es ist immer alles super eilig. Du kriegst es immer auf den letzten Drücker.
Du hast nicht wirklich Zeit, dich auseinanderzusetzen. Und das ist ja auch,
wir haben in der Vorbereitung auf die Sendung mal so ein bisschen geguckt nach
Stellungnahmen und offenen Briefen und wir haben den von 2020 nochmal gelesen,
wo sich Leute, NGOs zusammengetan haben und gesagt haben, wir brauchen mehr Zeit.
Ein Großteil von uns arbeitet ja auch nicht nur beruflich, sondern auch ehrenamtlich
an sowas. und eine der Forderungen, ich hab's nämlich nochmal rausgeschrieben,
war, dass wir mindestens vier Arbeitswochen wollen für einen langen,
komplexen Gesetzentwurf.
Das sind natürlich, die Forderungen waren da auch noch drin,
dass der gesamte Prozess transparenter sein soll.
Also ja, mehr Synopsen, eine Synopse ist, wenn man so eine Gegenüberstellung
hat der Änderungen, damit arbeitet sich das leichter.
Ich hab den Eindruck, dass es sich eher zuspitzt, aber geht ja auch einher mit
einem zugespitzten politischen Klima, ja.
Also ich denke, was sich heute Politiker sagen, habe ich vor 15 Jahren im Bundestag noch nicht erlebt.
Da war das alles ein bisschen höflicher. Auch ein bisschen distanzierter vielleicht.
Andererseits, dass Zivilgesellschaft dabei ist und dass sie in der Regel auch
einen Techie haben, also man denkt, da war ja ein Techie dabei,
das ist für mich selbstverständlicher geworden.
Also es ist nicht mehr so, dass es irgendwie seltsam ist, dass man jemanden
mal fragt, wie der technisch funktioniert.
Das ist für mich selbstverständlicher geworden. Aber eine gewisse Diese Frustration
habe ich häufiger nach den Anhörungen. Das kommt vor.
Auch wenn ich es nur angucke, also wenn ich jetzt nur den Stream nutze,
was ich super toll finde, dass es das gibt. Leute können, auch wenn es sehr
wenige tun, wie ich weiß.
Also sehr wenige gucken tatsächlich den Stream. Aber dass sie teilnehmen können
und sich anhören können, finde ich super wichtig.
Und dass alle Ausschüsse, wo ich das jemals erlebt habe, auch darauf achten,
dass Menschen im Stream, wenn es dann funktioniert, manchmal ist es ja am Anfang,
geht dir ja auch ein Feldbad aus, aber die versuchen mitzunehmen.
Das finde ich schon cool.
Und auch fort kann man dabei sein. Also man kann sich ein paar Tage vorher beim
Ausschussbüro anmelden und dann einfach oben sitzen auf der Rühne und sich das
mal angucken. Auch das ist ganz interessant und da sitzen immer wieder Leute.
Also das finde ich schon ein wichtiges Zeichen. Aber das ist vielleicht auch
ein guter Punkt, um mal zu fragen, hey, unterm Strich, was glaubt ihr denn,
was ist denn eigentlich der Mehrwert?
Für euch ganz individuell in diesen Ausschüssen dabei zu sein.
Ich frage erstmal Simone, die hat ja sozusagen jetzt gerade die frische Erfahrung.
Also ich finde es schon einfach eine wahnsinnig große Chance,
dass man als zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation da was einbringen kann und
da natürlich auch einfach Öffentlichkeit bekommt damit.
Und ich glaube, die Hoffnung ist ja schon, oder nicht nur Hoffnung,
es wird ja auch medial aufgegriffen.
Dadurch kann auch Kritik und eigene Ansichten nochmal einfach,
kriegt man da auch einfach nochmal mehr Reichweite.
Gleichzeitig hoffe ich schon, dass ein bisschen Rechtfertigungsdruck dann auch
entsteht, wenn am Ende doch die Argumente vielleicht doch nicht umgesetzt,
aufgegriffen werden oder so.
Ich glaube, was man sich schon einfach so realistisch vor Augen halten muss,
es kann ja gut sein, dass Argumente dann auch in der weiteren politischen Verhandlung
irgendwie in einem Kompromiss untergehen,
vielleicht irgendwie auch zur Verhandlungsmasse werden oder so.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es, würde ich sagen, die Chance, um Argumente vorzubringen.
Ich würde es ähnlich sehen. Also ich trotzdem öfter mal frustriert war nach
Anhörungen. Ich fand es auch immer nur Chance.
Und man muss Gespräch für nichts suchen. Und die Aufklärung,
gerade so bei Technik, jetzt bei mir, also ich fand es immer wichtig.
Und ich fand auch gut, dass ich auch immer Abgeordnete finde,
die sich dafür interessieren und Fragen stellen.
Das hat zwar ein bisschen so nachgelassen, aber ich habe das auch immer als Privileg empfunden.
Der Bundestag ist ein hohes Haus. Das sind gewählte Volksvertreter.
Die haben viele Stimmen bekommen und
Die Formen, ja letztlich die Gesetzgebung, ich fand das auch immer cool.
Also bei aller Privilegierung und so, aber was wären denn so Sachen,
also ich will mal gerne auf diese Ebene kommen, was könnte man sich eigentlich
in der idealen Welt vorstellen, wie es besser sein könnte?
Also wir wissen, wir leben in einer bestimmten Realität, wir haben bestimmte
Fraktionen, wir haben bestimmte Zwänge, auch zeitlicher Art und so,
aber wie reingeht das ideale Bild der Beteiligung von Experten,
Zivilgesellschaft, aber auch wegen meiner Akademie?
Was wäre das? Simone, muss man.
Also einen Aspekt hast du ja auf jeden Fall schon angesprochen,
das ist dieser zeitliche Aspekt.
Wir hatten da auch ein ganz krasses Beispiel, ich glaube es ging um die Reform
zum BND-Gesetz. Ich glaube so 24 Stunden, 88 Seiten Gesetzentwurf.
Ich meine, sowas darf halt eigentlich nicht sein.
Nein, genau, also Zeit ist ein Faktor, sowohl für die schriftlichen Stellungnahmen,
aber ich finde ehrlich gesagt, auch dann vor Ort in der mündlichen Anhörung,
wir haben jetzt ja gerade schon ein bisschen die Unterschiede gesehen,
wie es in den Bundesländern dann ist, einfach, dass so ein bisschen mehr Diskussion
zustande kommt, finde ich irgendwie schön und man so ein bisschen mehr Zeit
hat und man nicht so gezwungen ist.
Dass eine Frage, die eigentlich aus vielleicht dann doch mehr Fragen besteht,
vielleicht ganz kurz in zwei Minuten zu beantworten und dann bloß nicht zur
Vorsitzenden zu schauen, weil man schon weiß, dass man ein bisschen überziehen wird.
Ich glaube, das wäre ein großer Aspekt, den man bestimmt auch ein bisschen verwässern könnte.
Würdest du dazu stimmen? Oder fehlen dir noch andere Sachen ein,
die man in so einer idealen Welt gerne hätte?
Ich stimme da auf alle Fälle zu, was die Arbeit im Vorfeld angeht,
mit mehr Zeit auch eine bessere Zurverfügungstellung von Dokumenten,
Arbeitsständen und so weiter, gerade wenn es um konkrete Gesetzesentwürfe geht.
Das wird besser, aber ist immer noch verbesserungsbedürftig.
Und ich würde mir ehrlich gesagt wünschen, dass es auch eine Art von Nacharbeitung
gibt, dieser Diskussion.
Also da sind ja dann sieben mehr oder minder mit Expertise ausgestattete Menschen,
die Standpunkte vertreten und die Vorschläge machen.
Ja genau, die machen auch Vorschläge, stimmt.
Also das ist ja teilweise schon sehr konkret oder die auch sagen,
aus diesen, jenen Gründen geht es nicht und dann passieren manche Dinge aber
trotzdem oder manche Dinge werden nicht umgesetzt.
Es gibt ja überhaupt keinen Referenzpunkt, an dem der Ausschuss oder dann die
Ministerien oder das Kabinett, die dann quasi die finalen Entwürfe festfertigstellen,
da sich mal nochmal drauf beziehen.
Und das ist was, wo du halt nie weißt, ey, wurde über meinen Punkt jetzt eigentlich
diskutiert oder ist das so Verhalt? Und vielleicht ist es jetzt so ein bisschen
sehr egozentrisch gesprochen, aber ich hätte das gerne sichtbar gemacht.
Was passiert eigentlich mit der Expertise, die wir da einbringen?
Und ich glaube, dass das, na klar, das ist eine Mehrarbeit, aber ich glaube,
das wäre auch so ein bisschen im Sinne des respektvollen Miteinanders ein total wichtiges Zeichen.
Wir haben damals, als es diesen offenen Brief gab, also 2020,
das war so eine Initiative von vielen NGOs, wir haben damals geschrieben,
diese Sachverständigenanhörung und generell die Hinzuziehung von Expertise sollte
nicht zur Simulation verkommen.
Ich fand das einen harten Begriff, aber manchmal hat man natürlich schon den
Eindruck, da muss eben eine Sachverständigenanhörung stattfinden.
Eigentlich ist es politisch von zum Beispiel allen oder der Mehrheit der regierenden
Parteien gewollt, dass es genauso kommt.
Eigentlich wollen die nicht die Gegenargumente hören, weil letztlich ist das,
was die Sachverständigen oft anbringen, wo es nämlich Kritik gibt.
Da kommt ja selten mal ein Sachverständiger und sagt,
Ja, okay, finde ich super. Sondern die kommen und haben an einzelnen Punkten
große und kleinere Kritikpunkte.
Und oft, also menschlich kann ich es auch irgendwie verstehen.
Natürlich, wenn man sich jetzt an dieser Kritik abarbeiten und wenn man seine
politische Agenda durchbringt, dann steckt ja auch oft eben politischer Wille
hinter und nicht nur der Blick auf die Details, zum Beispiel die rechtlichen oder technischen.
Insofern, ich habe ein bisschen Verständnis dafür. Aber mit euren Vorschlägen
würde man diese Dilemma leider auch nicht lösen. Habt ihr noch bessere?
Also ich meine, weil letztlich, es ist detaillierte und manchmal auch sehr grundsätzliche
Kritik, wie kann denn ein hohes Haus überhaupt damit umgehen,
wenn politisch was gewollt ist,
ja, die wollen halt Gesichtserkennung geben, also ein Teil zum Beispiel,
ja, wenn man dann sagt, ja, aber da gibt es doch wirklich,
also Privatsphäre-mäßig, informationelle Selbstbestimmung oder diskriminierungsmäßig
oder so, echte Kritikpunkte, wie sollen sie damit umgehen, wenn es ihr politischer
Wille ist, ja, müssen wir da an die Wahlen ran, können wir da bei Sachverständigen
anhören, eigentlich so wie normalen,
repräsentative Demokratie gebaut ist, eigentlich überhaupt was macht.
Das sollten wir doch auch gar nicht, oder? Also wir sollten doch jetzt hier nicht so eine,
Expertokratie ins Leben rufen. Ich glaube, das will niemand von uns.
Aber da vielleicht nochmal einfach für mehr Transparenz zu sorgen,
um dann im Nachhinein den Finger in die Wunde zu legen.
Um zum Beispiel mal zu sagen, das Ding wurde vor dem Verfassungsgericht abgesägt,
weil es auch schon in den ganzen Stellungnahmen bei den Anhörungen kritisiert wurde. Und zu Recht.
Und deswegen machst du so großartige Arbeit, Simona. Aber genau,
ich glaube, dass diese Geschichten müssen wir viel mehr erzählen.
Und je besser wir das belegen können oder vielleicht auch mal quantifizieren
können, Datanaut irgendwie, also das fände ich auch schon mal spannend.
Aber that said, okay.
Gehen wir mal davon aus, so wie ihr jetzt darüber sprecht, ihr würdet trotzdem,
wann immer ihr als Sachverständige eingeladen werdet, auch wieder tun.
Also dass ihr jetzt trotzdem mit Kritik daran gebt, ihr würdet es nochmal tun, oder?
Auf jeden Fall,
Solange es nicht die AfD ist.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Ich habe das auch im Bundestag schon mehrfach gehört. Ich weiß nicht,
wie es in den Landtagen ist, aber die haben tatsächlich auch Probleme.
Es sind auch oft dieselben, die für die AfD im Innen- und Rechtsausschuss sitzen.
Man kennt die ja dann auch schon.
Also Einschläge auch in Rechtenforen, bekannte Juristen in der Regel, aber sonst niemand.
Und manchmal schaffen die auch nicht die Anzahl. Die haben ja relativ,
also die könnten ja oft auch zwei Sachverständige berufen.
Die schaffen auch nicht nur nicht die Anzahl, die schaffen auch nicht die Qualität.
Okay, also dann würde ich mal sagen, vielen Dank für sozusagen die Einblicke,
die ihr ja letztlich Leuten, die noch nie in diesen Sachverständigen-Anhörungen
gegeben habt, aber würdet ihr auch normalen Leuten mal empfehlen,
sich die Streams mal anzusehen oder lohnt sich das für dich?
Also was würdet ihr sagen?
Kommt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen auf das Thema an, aber ich finde,
wenn ein Thema dabei ist, an dem man sowieso Interesse hat, dann ist das natürlich
irgendwie, glaube ich, ganz interessant,
aber dann ist es vielleicht auch noch mal ein bisschen interessanter,
wenn man in Berlin wohnt, auch einfach Einfach zum Beispiel einfach reinzugehen
und so live dabei zu sein, dann kriegt man so ein bisschen mehr Atmosphäre noch mit, finde ich.
Und vielleicht auch die zivilgesellschaftliche Vertretung eurer Herzen da ein
bisschen zu unterstützen, weil das ist manchmal auch ganz schön aufregend, nervenaufreibend.
Und da zu wissen, es ist wichtig und Leute hören zu, das ist,
finde ich, mit eines der krassesten Signale, um ehrlich zu sein.
Meiner Erfahrung ist eigentlich auch, dass sich viele von den schriftlichen
Stellungnahmen, die ja samt und sonders im Landtag und im Bundestag dann auch
verfügbar sind, meistens nach einer Zeit oder so, oder sogar auf die Protokolle.
Es gibt ja in einigen Ausschüssen Wortprotokolle, dass es sich durchaus lohnt zu lesen.
Also ich habe das schon bei Themen, die ich so recherchiert habe oder wo ich
mich eingearbeitet habe, mit großem Interesse gelesen. Also ich finde, das lohnt sich auch oft.
Viele Sachverständige geben sich auch so inhaltlich sehr viel Mühe und schreiben.
Also sehr schöne Stellungnahmen.
Ja, na gut, dann wollen wir mal sagen, vielen Dank Simone, dass du bei uns bei Dicke Bretter warst.
Ja, danke, dass ich da sein durfte.
Ein Gruß an die Chaos Radio Crew, die wieder unsere Audioproduktion benimmt.
Wir hoffen, wir haben euch eine adäquate Qualität geboten in Bezug auf Audio
und die Crew versucht immer das Beste daraus zu machen.
Dann sagen wir, wollen wir schon sneaken, welche Thema wir nächstes Mal haben?
Ich weiß es eigentlich schon, wann wir sneaken.
Na dann sneake du, wenn du es weißt.
Na zumindest, wenn wir das nächste Mal, wenn wir Dicke Bretter 11 aufnehmen,
ein bisschen stärker in die Kommunal- und Landespolitik gehen,
die wir so ein bisschen außen vor gelassen haben in unserem Podcast bisher.
Und das werden wir machen bei einem ganz großartigen Event, das schon lange
Tradition hat, nämlich bei den Datenspuren in Dresden. In Dresden,
genau. Also kommt vorbei. Da freuen wir uns schon.
Ich glaube, wir werden vielleicht sogar live auf der Bühne sitzen.
Mal gucken. Denn vielen Dank, Simone, dass du da warst. Tschüss, liebe Raut-Hörerin.
Tschüss. Tschüss.